let's talk about the absolute number one
best remedy for unclogging or cleaning
out your arteries now what is a clogged
artery it's an artery that's filled with
plaque plaque is a Band-Aid composed of
partially fibrin which is a kind of a
connective tissue protein and partially
calcium a lot of times when you have
plaque you also have stiffening of the
artery you also have a lot of
inflammation that attracted this plaque
in the first place many times you also
have Associated high blood pressure
that's what a clogged artery is so the
perfect remedy would include this um
reduction of cholesterol and I'm talking
about the oxidative LDL which is a kind
of a pathogenic type cholesterol and we
also include something that would break
up this fibrin this protein that causes
this this clotting action but a perfect
remedy wouldn't give you any additional
side effects either right like for
example the medication stud does the
Statin have some side effects well it's
fascinating how they promote Statin One
Drug involving 2 000 healthy people over
the age of 50 which by the way showed a
50 reduction in your risk of getting a
heart attack and this is non-fatal heart
attacks okay reduction of 50 that sounds
pretty attractive but if you actually
study the study you're going to find out
that wasn't a 50 reduction in heart
attacks it was actually only a one
percent decrease risk and heart attacks
and just by manipulating the numbers and
using something called relative risk
reduction versus something called
absolute risk reduction you can enhance
these numbers to make them sound very
effective and without getting too far
into the woods absolute risk basically
is talking about the actual chance of
you getting a heart attack it's
comparable to like your chances of
getting hit with lightning right but
when we get into what's so-called
relative risk okay let me just explain
what that means well this particular
five-year study that I just mentioned if
we take the group that was given the
placebo not statins there's a 98 chance
of success of getting no heart attacks
okay and then if we look at the group
that was given the Statin the chance of
not having a heart attack was 99 in the
Statin group but if we look at these
numbers a little bit different and we go
from
two out of 100 let's say to 100 and
divide those two numbers we get 50
because one is 50 of to not many people
are going to be too motivated to take
the struggle there's only like a one
percent difference so they have to
manipulate the numbers to motivate
people to take this drug but on top of
this one percent decreased risk of
getting heart attack
there is a five percent increase risk of
some slight minor complications called
side effects myopathy which is muscle
problems and muscle disease you also
have erectile dysfunction you have low
testosterone neuropathy dementia
hemorrhagic stroke yes that's right
stroke increases as you decrease the
non-fatal heart attack and an increase
in cancer and of course they don't
mention the relative risk of that
increase by five percent instead they
just kind of focus on that 50 decrease
so the perfect remedy would not have
these serious side effects and this
remedy has been used by the Japanese for
over two thousand years and the remedy
is called NATO kinase NATO kinase is an
enzyme it's the most prevalent
ingredient
in NATO which is fermented soybeans
which is a really popular uh side dish
that the Japanese
consume and of course is fermented
soybean made out is loaded with vitamin
K2 now I don't know if NATO kinase has
vitamin K2 but NATO definitely has
vitamin K2 now let me just tell you a
little bit about uh this NATO kinase
because it's
you would think it'd be in every
newspaper around when you really study
it and learn about what it could do but
it's quite fascinating first of all it's
a very potent fibroletic
compound It's A protein that helps with
the clotting process so natokinase
breaks up clots potently and one
experiment they showed a decrease of
thrombosis by 88
within six hours so it's a great
dissolver of this protein in fact
they're also using it to help dissolve
nasal polyps that give people a lot of
sinus issues it has a very direct effect
on the LDL that's oxidized like
oxidative LDL which is involved in this
clotting it has very strong
anti-inflammatory properties because you
have to realize that the inflammation
started this whole problem in the first
place and the endothelial wall of that
artery which is the inside layer cell of
that artery becomes damaged probably
from either sugar or
omega-6 fatty acids or smoking or
whatever and then here comes the
Band-Aid the plaque without the
information chances are you're not going
to accumulate the Band-Aid in the first
place the other cool thing about NATO
kinase is its ability to lower blood
pressure middle kinase inhibits or
suppresses with thickening of that
artery wall it also increases the HDL
and lowers the triglycerides it was also
shown in a study in 2004 to decrease the
risk of Strokes because what it could do
for the brain mainly people get plaque
in the coronary arteries around the
heart but you can also get them in the
carotids through here too and once today
they combined datokinase with ginseng
and actually observed a shrinkage of
plaque in the aorta now yes it was in
animal studies and rabbits
but if you have a pet rabbit that is
developing plaquin in their aorta now
you have a remedy but in addition to all
those positive effects there was
virtually no adverse effects
so NATO kinase is something you
definitely want to look into if you have
placking or want to start to reduce your
quacking in your arteries now there's a
bit more information on plaquin
especially as it relates to vitamin K2
if you have not seen my video that got
10 million views related to the best
meal to take to clean out your arteries
you should definitely check that out I
put it up right here